boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still at cough as the Congress on
the future of engineering software for
our second annual partnership with them
we are now sitting down with Peter
thorne hello oh hello thank you for
coming on to our show we greatly
appreciate it I appreciate the
invitation we're very excited to talk to
you about everything that you're working
on can Bash's been around for a really
long time you've been with them as a
director for 24 years that's Ron which
is a very long time to be working in
engineering software field there combate
she's doing industry knowledge for
business advantage helping companies
selling and marketing engineering
software we're gonna be talking about
market data consulting training IOT
charter program and yourself pyramid all
this cool stuff before we get there
Peter let's talk about you how did you
even get interested in engineering
software I was doing science and
computer science at University and the
part of that that I enjoyed the most was
the 3d graphics in computer science and
so it was a kind of natural destination
for me so a very early job out of
university was real-time software
related to driving 3d graphics systems
which you know at the time was a big
deal they were expensive boxes and and
so on and that took me in I got into
contact with an application teams
initially in ship design and then in
process plant design and then later
moving on to general-purpose drafting
systems and 3d modeling systems I did a
lot of that as a developer part of that
work was on the time more on the user
side actually on the ship design
projects and then for me the natural
progression was in to kind of project
management and marketing and that sort
of stuff and eventually I ended up at
cam Bashi because I guess I had a head
full of what was going on in the
engineering software market
and when you're seeing this evolution of
these of computing and engineering
software over the span of time leading
up to your work with kam Bashi what were
some of the big sort of aha moments
about personal computing and about the
revolution of design software I think
for me the big milestones were firstly
understanding or trying to understand
the difference between geometry as you
know the shape of everything and what is
a product model what is the data that
truly describes the object you're trying
to design understand manufacture use and
service and in terms of the industry I
feel the industry spent too much time
stuck on geometry because you know
geometry was an interesting hard problem
to solve with computers if you go back
to the 80s and early 90s and was
relatively slow to be able to see that
products were more than just geometry
and it was very necessary to handle more
than just geometry now things have moved
on you know people we've the industry
has got a better grasp of what it has to
deal with in order to write useful
software and provide useful tools for
design engineers interesting so this
sort of attachment to getting the
geometry right was kind of a it was kind
of like a first principle to drive they
wanted to get the if the right ways of
describing what was appearing in
geometry on the tude on the on the 2d
surface but in 3d which is a very
complicated process that's right and
it's a an absolutely necessary important
part of systems but it's not the whole
story
you know so when you think about a new
product introduction actually it starts
with requirements how do you map
requirements into geometry that's really
really hard
in fact what you have to do is start
with requirements map those into
functions and functions then can make
their way into geometry and if that's
your mindset you are far more likely to
be successful in providing a set of
tools which are going to make sense to a
design engineer as an end user so yeah
it that don't let me try and downplay
geometry is critically important but and
it took the industry a long time to get
enough of that right to be able to move
on but you know that I even even now
that has been solved I suppose for more
than ten years there are not many
systems that are stuck on just geometry
now and you would we could say that it's
solved well it's pretty it's never
solved as okay as you know this industry
there is always room for something no no
and we can see that here at cold fast
you know startup companies offering new
approaches and you know they're
interesting and some of them are going
to be hugely successful yes now what you
would you then say that when when you
when you're taking a a what you're
attempting to put into a 3d space on a
2d surface these geometries and you're
putting them inside of some sort of a of
a new aiming to make a function that
that that that process of finding out
how to how to make that actually occur
at its most optimal level it's is that
is that more of a process of the actual
software being able to take what you
would like for the fort for for for the
optimizing the function is that kind of
is it a saw is it is it a software buy
software can different software's would
make it potentially easier to for the
function
partly the way I would it would try to
explain it is you've got to give the
engineer different concepts to work with
one of those concepts is geometry but
actually you need to be able to navigate
around a much broader set of artifacts
data you know in they would originally
have been documents before computers you
need to be able to navigate around and
have access to ways of describing of
interrogating and understanding
first of all requirements and then
functions before you get to the
specifics of specifics of geometry and
there are different ways of doing that
soon as systems engineering people often
talk about requirements functions
logical model and a physical model and
the geometry part is only in the
physical model you know one of four
steps of the sort of big thinking of how
you put a product together so the key
thing is giving the engineer the ability
to go to any of those places in the
description of the of the product and in
quite sometimes quite interactive ways
you don't know whether they're going to
spend you're in the middle of working on
some detail of geometry and to take the
next step
actually you've got to stop and think do
I really understand the requirement no I
don't I'll go and look you know and and
that's where the software needs to be
able to follow the train and and
software can now can do this click click
click on the geometry and you jump up
the levels to to see the requirement hmm
and at that point you can then say yes
now I can remember what we really should
be doing and what how to trade off the
constraints around this area of our
design click click click back and you
can do the right thing in geometry so
it's navigation it's the connected
nature of all of these different types
of model
those things all work together then
you're gonna have a happy engineer who
feels that this computer model is
offering all the right access points to
make changes to ask questions to do
simulations yeah and so on
interesting so a lot of this is about
the engineer having a really strong kind
of tool belt to be able to go and poke
and prod you said double-click into
certain areas and see exactly what those
requirements were double-click back out
go to the different area and you have to
swap things out run simulations this is
all kind of what the what the the tool
belt can be for for engineers and that's
what engineering software can optimally
become yes and now that we've got to
that point you know now it's time to
take the next step with the current
situation actually it can be quite quite
difficult to understand if you try to
draw a diagram of how these things work
you find your drawing diagrams over the
various views of the product you know be
requirements or the functions or the
physical model and then you end up
drawing lots of arrows as to how they
connect together because as you can
imagine one requirement can give rise to
a number of different functions there
and then you know say three or four
different functions and they can be
implemented in a number of different
ways you know there might be a
mechanical solution with geometry there
might be an electronic solution this is
will be done by the software in you know
the control board of the product that
has you know so can can drive motors and
do things that you need to enable that
function so yeah you end up with a
diagram with a lot of arrows on it and
you know you scratch your head and think
wow you know engineers have held this
stuff in their heads oh yeah you know
and that's what they have to do and in
fact they have to hold multiple version
in their heads yeah because at any one
time it's a bit like playing chess you
know you're thinking of what is the
strategy here what is the next step I've
got six options on the go which one
should i velop to see if it's the best
and you know the great designers can
very quickly pick the one that that is
going to produce the best result just
like give the good chess players know
that they need to develop play on this
side of the board or something like that
yeah yeah Wow when you make when you put
it into perspective where there's so
many different of these arrows
connecting when you make changes how it
influences so many other parts and for
someone to be able to make the decision
on for four customers of what is going
to be the best most successful decision
that is that is a very very cool way of
thinking about the decisions that come
from these from from companies about
products that they're making now how did
the how did the first transition happen
to kam Bashi for you it was slightly
strange actually I had known the founder
and owner of kam Bashi for many years
while I was doing other other things and
at one point I was changing jobs just
continuing in the sort of mainstream
vendor user world of engineering
software um and I was about to be
offered a job but I needed a reference
so I went to this you know contact
colleague friend of mine from for and
asked for a reference and we got talking
and instead of taking the job that I'd
been offered I ended up at kam Bashi so
yeah it was just it was a curious story
totally not deliberate from my point of
view but I had a great conversation I
thought actually you know that suits my
character of just being
interested nosy what the Australians
would call stickybeak stickybeak where
you just you you just want to know about
everything that's going on
yeah and the world of Industry Analysts
consulting that's that's what you do you
know you dip in and out of projects with
clients sometimes over a period of years
so you can see things through from
concept to completion but you're not
involved all but you're dealing with you
know multiple clients and you're in
multiple different types of projects but
it was kind of an accident yeah and then
what was this like twenty four years ago
compared to maybe ten years ago compared
to now in terms of what industries are
you analyzing the most also what types
of projects are you guys taking on if we
go back 24 years there was the first of
all there were still more vendor
companies in the market you know there's
been a lot of consolidation so there's
other one you know just fifteen maybe
significant players in the market which
meant that end-users were asking for
advice about who were the strong players
in what sort of area so that was an
important part since with the
consolidation going on from cam Bash's
point of view that has seemed to be less
of a demand from a user's mouth and
there was still you know twenty four
years ago there were still questions of
does this really work you know so there
were vendors who really wanted to be
able to demonstrate that their stuff
worked and you know camber she could
play a part in that either in helping
you know review case studies and see how
a particular set of implementations
should be enough to give you know new
prospects
confidence that you know the solution
would work in their environment
and I guess also for Kobashi at least in
what for me were the early days of
camber she's many more of the projects
were custom designed projects so whereas
now camber she has invested in its own
research and development to produce
licensable data and materials and and so
on so just off-the-shelf content in
those early days it was very much a
let's talk to a prospective client talk
about the problems see if we can design
if not a complete answer at least a
project which will help move the client
towards an answer so you know the
shorter version of that is to say the
transition has been from that kind of
custom project environment to much more
kind of license data services type of
environment yeah yeah that that seems to
be a reoccurring theme of what we've
been as we've been sitting down to
people we've been hearing more and more
about the services that are now at
provided on the cloud that engineering
software can can can keep engineers can
choose to use any cloud computations and
that they that they desire for their
projects versus maybe what used to be
doing a project as a consulting firm for
the that engineering team now the
engineering team can maybe go out and
find the algorithms and the processes
that they need so then with with maybe
let's go a little bit closer to today
then what are some of the most because
they're these these fields of market
data consulting and training or what are
we unpack these for us and how can Bosch
she does what it does in those fields
I suppose we ended up with that kind of
structure but um because it was all
based on our research work so what we
found especially our engineering
software
and clients were asking for there's
information about industry so we as
trying to satisfy that need we
researched industries and when we
research industries we get two types of
information both qualitative and
quantitative so it's kind of natural to
capture that information so the
quantitative data went in one direction
towards our market sizing datasets and
the qualitative information went in
another direction which was towards the
training material that we use voluntary
in an industry training and then of
course you know it's never a perfect fit
for what a client wants so we added
professional services to the offer
well added that was more a continuation
of the traditional business from you
know 20 years ago but instead of
inventing solutions and projects it was
more with how to use the assets of the
data and the industry content and
knowledge sort of inside the training
materials to solve a particular problem
so we ended up with the with the three
lines of business the market data where
you can license a spreadsheet that tells
you about the revenue engineering
software revenues in in the market the
training business where you can license
material to find out about particular
industries you know so pharmaceuticals
or high-tech or machinery and if just
using those off the shelf that
off-the-shelf content isn't enough then
we'll step in and help you use that
stuff yeah yeah
and then when what are you seeing as the
most common a market data that people
are most interested the most common
training that people are interested in
using through you
we did a on the training side it's at
least that's we've got a sort of
quantitative a sort of a quantitative
answer there so we had a couple of
licensees who between them reported
10,000 completions of modules within the
the training content so this gave us
when they said 10,000 so that's
wonderful you know that's enough
so we're gonna see what is the really
popular stuff and we got pretty
consistent use over all of the modules
and what was each time we thought we'd
found something you know and I remember
it particularly and there were the two
clients involved and one of them from
one of them there were two training
modules that were relatively under use
so great we found something that we can
can't cross off the list or doesn't need
to be updated too often or something
like that and then we went and looked at
the other client and lo and behold those
two were right at the top of their list
of the obvious so you know in terms of
training I suppose we're quick sort of
glad that that is the situation because
our industry training is designed for
professionals who are trying to work
with people in these industries so they
need to learn the language they need to
understand the business issues so they
can talk to somebody in that industry
and have a meaningful conversation yes
yes and you know if they're a technology
vendor they or a services vendor they
can position their offer in terms that
they have yeah the person they're
speaking to will understand and I guess
what we were seeing was that perhaps
there was more
a sort of general use of the training
content so people were thinking oh
crikey I've got a meeting with a
pharmaceutical company this afternoon
so I'll spend half an hour this morning
in the training content to just make
sure I'm up to speed on the words and so
on that's a great business development
skill set if you're taking a meeting
with an industry that you could use over
fresher on learn some of their in
nomenclature that they use please just
take the 30 minutes to learn about the
company about the some of the words that
they use that type of stuff because
you're gonna have a higher success rate
with that conversation build more
rapport relate to their work more this
is where these trainings come in I think
in really great help for building
stronger bonds between people yes yes
and we found our training actually works
for two different types of trainee of
learner so there are you know we've seen
our training content the level 100 type
content used in the onboarding process
where new members of staff are just
brought into a company and you know go
through the training so that they can
work in you know some some sectors but
we've also seen it used when experienced
people move from one area to another and
those experience be you know they not
absolutely know how to work with
customers they've got all of the skills
and actually our training we're not
trying to teach the skills we're trying
to provide the content you know as you
say the main touch of the business
issues that kind of stuff and for
experienced people they can use our
stuff and very quickly get what they
need to have those conversations and
then on the market data side would have
been some of the popular so
probably the main differentiator for us
and that probably has led to the main
use of our data is the detail that we
provide for global data by country and
by industry interesting so you know we
cover we provide data for 56 countries
and within each country we actually
research and model wait for it a hundred
and twelve industry sectors now well you
see you would be quite right to react
and say that's crazy yeah and you're all
right nobody needs a hundred and twelve
sectors point is we work with a range of
clients and they all think of their
vertical industries they have slightly
different definitions sure so they're
all completely right that you need you
know on a scale of 7 or 10 vertical
sectors to organize a corporation and we
have to do 112 so that we can map the
industries to our clients industries and
get a good fit to that so the main use
you know for the big corporations
dealing with many countries it's in
marketing planning which really means
resource allocation budget allocation
and also target setting so one of the
main bits of feedback that we get when
we just bump into people you know
traveling around the world are the sales
teams on the sales managers who say ah
come Bashi
you're the source of our sales targets
aren't you and we say well no no not us
weird we just haven't evidently you know
that you know your your company is a
client of ours and they must have used
our numbers to help set your sales
targets so yeah its marketing planning
resource allocation target setting lay
news and I saw one of the images that
you were sharing regarding the regarding
this market data that you end up
analyzing and then licensing because
there's a for almost four and a half
billion people in Asia and the market
for engineering software there is
growing GDP is the highest there in the
world and then so then how do you then
end up figuring out out of the you know
56 countries 112 of these subcategories
which one then is you know that you're
really trying to do to either both look
at as well as why are other people
looking at it is it because there's like
the most amount of of of interest in
Asia is in biotech and you're looking at
that it said can you explain how this of
these sort of market data analyst
analyzing happens and why it's so
important the research uses a huge
number of different sources I mean you
know we started trying to count the
sources and kind of gave up when we hit
about 800 or 900 so I guess we're
talking about you know a few thousand
maybe two or three thousand sources of
data and that includes all of the
company reports but it also or all of
the provider reports all the financial
reports that are available which are
legally supposed to be correct which are
legally correct yes yes but of course
those reports only cover a percentage of
the market there are all the private
companies as well and the
the unlisted companies where the data is
just different if it's available at all
yeah so we go to a huge number of
sources and and we try to maintain we
try to obtain information from at least
three independent sources yes yes a
provider's is a really important one
yeah but actually country information
yeah is another one so most countries
have a moderately well often a reliable
national statistics office they mainly
have good company registries so that you
can get some sort of filed accounts you
know from local countries even for the
global players so if there's a country
source and then we look for industry
sources as well and around the world
industry associations provide often
quite good survey type information of
their members and you know indicators of
growth and size of market and the use of
softwares and so on and what we do is
triangulate between these different
sources in order to try and homed in on
what we would regard is the best
estimate of the market and you know you
can think of that process as a kind of
giant game of pseudo coup where you know
it has to add up to a hundred percent
because that's what it must be and
whether that's by industry or by country
or for a particular provide interesting
based on their like total GDP that
you're looking at a certain percentage
of the industry has to add up yeah and
and it's more than that you know it can
be within a country sometimes you will
find you know and Kure surprisingly
sometimes it's surprising countries have
done this their National Statistics
Office will have done surveys about the
way that money is invested because that
the owner governments are interested in
this so is the taxman
in most countries and
and they all provide information that
way and they can divide up the
categories of spend into and if we're
lucky for a particular country
it will include software and sometimes
categories as well and that just gives
you another view to compare with the
reports by the financial reports the
legal reports the legally binding
reports from from the vendors this
triangulation in game of Sudoku is very
interesting to be able to figure out
what these truths are and be able to
share them with other entities that are
then organizations that are trying to
query this data to make it to help it to
help make sense of what's happening
around the world where they should be
investing or looking yeah if you're just
seeing software in Asia well is that
broken down further can we double click
and see all of the separate categories
of software like without dates the
answer is yes yes actually you can
double click down to individual vendors
it's great and you can double click
again to get to product groups from
individual then that's crazy whoa so ok
so we're talking like double click in
two years or double click into software
double click into into a customer
relationship management CRM stuffed and
in fact that's out of our scope with
advanced engineering soft yeah just
engineering so double click into
engineering and software double click in
the CAD or PLM right you don't click an
appeal that maybe and then you can see
based on on group so maybe it's like
preventative maintenance right and then
maybe you double click into that yes we
tend to by the time you get to the yes
we do offer an analysis by technologies
but they're the the high level
technology is so CAD CAE you know
digital manufacturing here lambda oh
that sort of level yeah
but we also provide the numbers for an
individual company so you
sometimes companies use those to judge
market share that's because if we can
see you know it's named provider and you
can see then how much like PTC or how
much Autodesk is affecting like North
America in terms of engineering software
who owns or what percentage of the
market shares absolutely yes that is all
part of our data and we routinely send
out date the data that we have about an
individual company to that company for
comment and yeah some well and sometimes
they'll reply and say yes that's right
your it or the public companies are
really quite restricted legally on what
they can say to us but I think in all
cases where we've made you know
significant errors in our estimates a
company concerns has been able to point
us towards a document has been published
as good that we can then use that's our
relationship in the community is for
everyone
you know it is useful if our estimates a
good estimates yeah more data yeah
absolutely
very interesting it's it's every
industry needs a combative II doing
analysis work every industry not just
engineering software biotech needs on
neuroscience neither one in my opinion
yes because I suppose at root of what we
are trying to do is to provide a
rational basis for decision making Chris
and we see that rational basis as being
the numbers you know understand the
numbers understand what the industry is
trying to do
and from that you can get your resource
allocation right and you can make
optimum decisions yeah and then it also
kind of you know speaks to on a
geopolitical level there are so many
different countries that have certain
amounts of investment into something
like engineering software well how much
is Asia investing into engineering
software how much is to North America
what are some of the maybe like
approximate that you can that you can
teach us about that that specific
question because it doesn't many in many
ways seemed like Asia's and engineering
is just you know four and a half billion
people so much GDP so much ability to
build build create across a lot of land
is that kind of is there like a big
curve heading up and for there I yes and
part of it is numbers so if you look at
China and employment numbers you know
actually I was just looking at the the
number of Engineers employed in China is
about the same as the total number of
people employed in North America Wow
so gonna say 400 million or something it
I dunno but it's a lot the exactly it's
a lot yes now if you drill down and look
at engineering software spend per
engineer or then it's very different you
know so I think China comes out at you
know maybe five hundred dollars per
engineer whereas in other countries it
can be two or three thousand dollars
spend per engineer yes what does that
mean in terms of software like this is
revenue received by the engineering
software providers
so it'll per employee per engineer her
engineer yeah all of them just just add
it all up okay total engineering
software revenue in China yeah yeah
divided by the number of
interprofessional engineers I get enough
okay the same thing in Netherlands the
Netherlands you get a different a much
higher number a much higher number which
means well the interesting it's kind of
there's an element of development of the
economy what stage are they aren't but
in fact if you look at in that
particular case the average country
spend and then looking at an individual
industry this is where you know big why
do we do all this in the industry
related stuff so take automotive is with
one that most clients are interested or
maybe all clients are intrinsically
actually the ratio between the spend per
engineer in automotive and the average
spend per engineer for the country as a
whole that is much less different
between China and other countries you
know so the relative intensity of spend
in automotive is kind of a same across
these countries and doing that sort of
ratio analysis for the marketing people
you know they get all sorts of insights
into what is the state of development in
this country how does this country
perceive a particular industry yeah and
that helps we believe that that helps
our clients develop strategies and
decide you know how many sales teams how
many support people should we be forming
partnerships to address you know
opportunities which we're perhaps not
covering at the moment
you can pull something relevant of that
out of the data and then this is this is
so important to be able to make these
analysis that have these relevant pulls
that you can pull from the data what
about this this idea that so many of the
the people I saw this in some of your
blog posts that most of the it's trades
people and machine operators is where
that we could potentially serve
available markets more that as if is
that does that mean that most of the
people at the top these architects and
designers engineers and technicians and
then management supervisors this sort of
these the lesser areas does that mean
that those lesser areas are that the way
that we need to that we need to
disseminate the the CAD and disseminate
the the just engineering designs down to
the trades people and machine operators
that that's what we're trying to include
we're trying to have them be included in
understanding what's been happening in
the smaller amounts of people to a
certain extent yes so so the yes part of
that is you know that's part of the
story of the single source of truth type
thinking of the the the fully digital
environment the digital twins the
connected environment you know yes if
that's going to work you need everyone
to have an appropriate access to that
information so they all everybody is
singing from the same song won the same
page in the songbook in fact I think the
biggest effect we've seen right now with
our clients is when we start talking
about employment and looking at some of
these numbers and you're right you know
there are these large numbers
larger numbers of technicians and
machine operators than there are
engineers which is just however how
things work it's possible to sort to
trigger a conversation that is all
around well what do we offer to those
people so our client a software vendor
will be looking at that and saying I
know about what we do with engineers but
hold on there are these technicians who
are working with them what do we offer
to those technicians and often the
answer is well it's the same they need
the same software but for the for their
customers the real end users to
understand that maybe the vendor has to
learn to present the information about
their offer in a different way yes to a
different audience and then suddenly you
know that the managers of the
technicians and the operators realize
that they should be spending budget in
this area as well so it's that kind of
effect often it's just looking at the
data and triggering conversations about
market strategies who are we going to
address how should we reach those Pizza
that's where the value comes from the
sort of combination of market size
information and employment type
information yeah yeah in the power of
storytelling the power of everyone seen
from the same page in the songbook yeah
yeah and then out of the you know
there's also this you you were
explaining the difference between your
qualitative and quantitative market data
give us again the the the idea of this
regarding your IOT charter program as
IOT is exploding the IOT is absolutely
exploding we got started in that area I
know five seven years ago but we
approached it from the kind of
engineering tools point of view so we
were looking at the tools used for
embedded systems development just what
you know and that was exactly what was
going on companies which had previously
been working in mainly mechanical in
environments found themselves working
with embedded electronics and software
in the electronics to build their their
products and you know as the market
developed and the major providers
started putting together IOT platform
software the kind of middleware between
the connected devices and the
applications which are going to drive
control monitor these connected devices
we anticipated that you know it was
really just extending our coverage of
this tools area the embedded systems
tools to incorporate this middleware
but to make sure of that we established
the charter program and we invited in
the clients who were potential buyers of
this data to talk to us about the
research program and we got some really
interesting responses because it turns
out that actually our clients were more
interested in the drivers of the market
that they were addressing of middleware
and and tools what were the drivers
going to be kinda yeah because they were
trying to suss for they are trying to
satisfy a wide range of applications
from connected workers to connected
production to connected assets to
connected products in in in the field
connected buildings connected cities you
know all of these things can be serviced
by this middle way so what the Charter
program achieved was to open our eyes I
suppose to our clients the vendors of
this middleware as to what they needed
in order to be able to plan their
business and that is guiding how
research in this area and so we're
putting much more into understanding
those connected application areas than
simple sizing of that sort of middleware
market so that's new for us and I think
it's really good feedback that we've had
from our charter program members this
also speaks to the point that you said
in your talk too about data being the
new oil because the amount of what they
you have to deal with the mid-middle
we're figuring out the sensor data
making it applicable to humans that are
trying to make decisions and they're in
the daily lives or even artificial
intelligence agent making decisions that
the sheer amount of data that is now
we're trying to make sense of and make
applicable to our lives it's just is it
now it's just beyond I mean I think it's
every two years so we make more data
than we did in the in previous previous
than that
so now in terms of the future that you
think we're heading to you know you have
engineering software kind of under a
pretty strong like global magnifying
lens you're you're looking into this
area of the world that area the world
breaking of engineering software down
into different levels here seeing how
things are ramping up in certain areas
it was just really cool but what is the
future that they're all kind of pointing
towards a lot of people see cloud a lot
of people see see generative design
there's all these different sort of
futures where do you see the trends
moving towards
I'm smiling because I've had a
conversation in this area where I my
conversation partner and I found the
easiest way to describe that vision was
to refer to Star Trek yeah yeah that's
it's there what do we expect to happen
in Star Trek you know Scotty asks
computer yeah you know so maybe in the
future Scotty will ask Alexa but do you
know or cereal or whoever but yeah
and in talking about design and you know
what do you expect in Star Trek of
course the computer can simulate any
kind of change that Scotty is suggesting
yeah to the machines and the devices you
know or on the enterprise and I think
that is actually a trend which is in
place now and is accelerating yeah and
it's simple expectation you know a
couple of maybe five years ago there was
a change made in the way that a
university I believe it was Boston
University but please don't quote me on
this because it was a definitely an East
Coast University the way they taught
programming to engineering students so
they had been working with you know
traditional programming languages so C
or even Pascal you know to to try and
embed the con all of the kind of
computer science type concept um but
they moved and they moved towards the
math works products they they had a
specific deal with that company and they
used MATLAB and Simulink
as the basis of their new approach to
teach programming to engineering
students now what's significant about
that the similar link as you can kind of
hear in the name enables very direct
visual simulation of the code that you
are creating so you can kind of see
what's going on you know you move boxes
around the screen you make links as the
way of building a model and what I
remember impressed me was the professor
involved reported a I think it was a it
was either a 5 or 6 X improved increase
in the number of students who took that
class yeah and what was the reason for
that was because it just was more
interactive it was you know programs
were no longer these static things which
you had to delve into the data and what
look at readouts of variables to see
what was going on you could just see it
yeah the sames happening in my opinion
with engineering design designers want
and need and appreciate some kind of
easily linked simulation to what they're
doing and if you think about that that
is so close to you know well what Scotty
would have done we without asking the
computer you know I'm gonna move I'm
gonna stick strengthen this beam by
making this thicker because in my mind
and Scott is what I know that's going to
be able to absorb the side loads on
listen this particular mechanism or
something like that cause in the more
complicated environment you need the
stimulation software yeah to give you
that sort of feedback as to what have
the changes that you've made actually
delivered yeah so I think that's gonna
be a big deal you know first of all the
growth of simulation generally in its
current mode which is kind of design it
and simulate it and design it and
simulators it's kind of that loop the
advanced systems are more interactive
than that where there's a meeting right
away immediate feedback available and
Wow that's the way people like working
yeah it feels as though that simulation
engineering simulation is able to run
through the permutations faster than the
human creative capability can and yeah
yeah and that's when that's when we get
lots of star treky and yeah yeah futures
and stuff like that
so absolutely I'm happy I'm happy that
you bring that up and then out of the
you know 21st century's here exponential
technology all these things are
happening what would be something
important for kids and adults to pick up
as a primary skill set
hmm I suspect well skillset I'm gonna
answer a slightly different question
because I still think is the desire to
take something apart to see how it works
amad is at the absolute core of whether
someone is going to enjoy and feel
fulfilled in this industry you know from
from almost as a user of the software as
a developer the software you know it's
it's that kind of instinct that's not
really well sometimes it's the skillset
I think it is I think that it's very
much so what you said is is definitely a
skill set yeah tinkering taking things
apart putting them back together
understanding how things work instead of
them being black box this is very
important but we have such a limited
amount of neuro real-estate to decide
which items we want to dedicate our
stimuli to and it's also try I agree but
yeah and it's becoming harder to do that
you know so for example I was talking to
a provider of electrical test equipment
you know absolutely for electrical type
engineers just the world of take it
apart see how it works
oh let's see you you know we can make
this better the kind of thinking however
they had realized that they were going
to be able to make better more
functional products at a lower cost if
instead of the physical electronics that
they had always used in the past they
replaced a lot of that with a
microcontroller and software to provide
the functions lo and behold there is no
longer any way of just poking into the
circuit to read a voltage and look at
the you know current flow and so on to
find out what's going on suddenly you do
need new skills to look inside that
integrated circuit and find out why the
software has decided to apply 5 volt
suddenly to this this terminal what
whatever it is so I think there are
certain skills which are not it's still
the instinct to take it apart that is
the driver for you wanting to build
these skills but yes you do need to
learn other things as well to be able to
you know take stuff apart yeah Peter
this has been super fascinating thank
you so much for joining us on the show
and teaching us about your work and
about cam Bashi about just understanding
what is going on in an engineering
software across the world in its finest
granularity so thank you delighted that
Lear invited me interesting conversation
today many thanks oh thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you think check out the links
to Peter's work to kim Bashi as well
also check out the links to Co Fez and
go and build the future support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in all of simulations links are
below and go and manifest your destiny
into the world thanks everyone for
tuning in and we will see you soon peace